we all know what anime is like right if
it's not super giant robots fighting
toiling wins or the supernatural
it's a sleazy love triangle and some
high school setting or if not a
combination of the four the main
character is always a lovable loser a
goody two-shoe for us all good or
depressed [ __ ] complaining by his
hairdo in the morning once in a while
though and then may comes along that
really does something new to stand out
from the crowd and really does make you
think and no I'm not talking about
animes like Evangelion unless you count
thinking us getting you're my sexually
assaulted by a man you can only speak
out his anus Death Note is an anime that
fits this description nicely an anime
that doesn't need super powered flights
or dine robots to be entertaining proven
that all you need to make a great show
is a notebook that can kill a Def Con
that has way too much spare time in his
hands and a rivalry between two boys in
their turn a mission to either kill each
other or toss each other off the story
goes something like this
a black notebook with the power to kill
predictably in fact with Death Note it's
dropped from the Shinigami worm to the
human world with a big sign next to it
saying oh I hope no one picks me up and
tries to use me for world domination
nudge nudge wink wink and in the end is
picked up by a main protagonist
Light Yagami that's why my case fell
backwards a week later light is visited
by the Shinigami who dropped it a guy
named Luke one ugly son of a [ __ ] looks
like a cross between Russell Brand Alice
Cooper and the Joker he saw looks like
someone told him the secret to eternal
youth but lied at any rate it seems that
light wants to rid the world of evil by
killing off criminals and coming mister
all in the name of justice apparently so
in the end we have our protagonist light
who has a notebook then kill with only
an aim in the face got me by one [ __ ]
ugly death God with an OCD super
detective teenager with the alias L
trying to catch them
not your typical anime concept is it now
definitely was a very interesting Henle
it's an anime that really requires you
to use your brain which makes his
popularity a mystery to me since for my
careful observations of YouTube I can
only conclude that about 90% of the
Internet is populated by a bunch of
[ __ ] M monkeys with half a brain I
can only speak through silly acronyms
and badly spells English don't worry I'm
not talking about you talking about the
guy next to you you know that guy
wearing that Morita headband scoffing on
Pocky and tossing off to him say yeah
that guy anyway I really enjoyed death
no it was an anime that constantly kept
me guessing till the end
we seem to be one step ahead me and I've
always flaunted the fact that it was
smarter and sharpened me the smug
bastard but that's okay since there are
times where I just have to sit back
admire and just applaud the intelligence
of the whole show it's just like
watching the most interesting game of
chess ever played well it is until a
third player's introduced and [ __ ]
everything up by talking about makeup
and boyfriends well let's not get on
that I also just love the rivalry
between N and light I mean on the
outside there were just the best of
buddies when they were secretly trying
to kill each other oh we all know they
love each other really and I was just
waiting for the moment where they just
stop arguing link to each other and just
kissed okay I'm just kidding
the seriously actually mentions that
they're gay and there was certainly no
gay overtones in it either here you're
still soaked I'm sorry
and no yeah we found goes that don't
concern here it I still can't help but
laugh though since the anime does take
itself too seriously it tries to make
every scene as epic as possible and
sometimes backfires with unintentional
comedy gold don't get me wrong the
scenes I've done well as epic as they
can be but I never thought I'd see the
day where I went I stopped watching an
episode thinking man without some epic
potato chip eating well prominently
laughing to myself and the whole
ridiculousness of the scene I'll take a
potato chip in II know what I couldn't
help but notice that even the potato
chip et petition of the series has has
even slipped to the live-action version
there she owner Donald oh gosh gotta say
is shawni kiddo scum a masher
I also find it amusing absolutely
everything in his anime is analyzed to
the bone like how an entire [ __ ]
absolutely spent on analyzing a tennis
game between Ellen lights personally I
was waiting for the episode where L
analyzes the logistics of like taking a
dump sadly that never came
all in all death now is probably one of
the most interesting animes I've ever
seen it will keep you on the edge of
your seats and occasionally pushes you
off yeah mission is great the soundtrack
is absolutely amazing and it probably
features one of the greatest rivalries
and animes but in the end it doesn't
matter who wins or loses because
ultimately they all lose to the star and
real main character of this show Matsuda
overall I give this and make a 9 out of
10